j'aime à l'opecst ok la vidéo elle
commence comme ça j'ai repris la salle
avant-hier et schéma complexe voilà bon
écouter ces derniers temps ça parle
beaucoup de sport et c'est chiant [ __ ]
laissez-nous pas aller à la salle sans
culpabiliser vous nous faites chier là
les beaux gosses qui court qui soulève à
lhassa qui font des postes l'instar ça
dégage laisser les flemmards tronquée
quoi je troll c'est génial grâce à vous
je me suis remis au sport et vous m'avez
tirer tous ensemble vers le haut et je
suis ravi d'être humilié chaque fois que
je vais à la salle car je soulève 10
kilos là où les autres soulève 44 bref
on n'est pas là pour parler de ça je me
suis remis au sport et du coup je me
renseigne beaucoup sur ça de plus en
plus en fait plus je grandis que je me
renseigne parce que c'est un truc à côté
duquel je suis complètement passé dans
ma vie mais vraiment j'en ai fait quand
j'étais très petit mais comment dire bah
voila j'ai fait un an de judo et on
faisait les animaux quoi vous savez
fallait faire des distances un coup en
faisant le cheval aux coûts en faisant
l'autriche c'est même plus beaucoup
d'habitats du judo d'ailleurs [ __ ]
bref
en fait j'ai fait du sport quand j'étais
très petit croisant jim un nom de judo
et un an des scream je crois mais quand
tu es très très petit c'est une approche
qui est très différente de cantat kanté
majeur ou cantat ne serait-ce que 15 16
ans du coup je sais pas ce que c'est le
vrai sport le vrai challenge la vraie
discipline en fait y compris au stade
professionnel et donc là en ce moment je
m'intéresse à tout ça je regarde des
petits événements ce qui s'est passé
quoi quand comment les réalités a battu
le record tout ce que je connais pas en
fait aujourd'hui avant compte chèques
des trucs mais moi j'ai pas vu je vais
vous parler de trucs que j'ai vu
justement et qui m'ont un peu fêlé fait
du duo
commençons tout ça avec une vidéo qui a
tourné d'ailleurs pas mal récemment sur
twitter qui est vraiment trop émouvant
je trouve ça s'est passé le 17 août 2014
lors des championnats d'europe féminins
d'athlétisme on est au 4 x 400 mètres
donc quelqu'un pour 400 mètres donne le
relais à un autre court 400 mètres donne
le relais et ça à 4 fois kouao
j'explique le 4 x 400 m mais tout le
monde je suis le pire proof bref floria
guinee58 prononcer son nom de famille
donc je veux pas l'offensé est ce que du
coup je le pense encore plus dense à
homer bref on est au quatrième relais
donc c'est les derniers 400 mètres et la
tête française est derrière trois autres
athlètes la grande bretagne
l'ukraine et la russie et elle a
beaucoup de retard et la tête française
floria elle fait un truc incroyable et
un truc que j'aime dans ces vidéos
sportif au delà de la prouesse sportive
qu'il ya dans la vidéo c'est les
commentateurs mais j'aimerais tellement
et amis avec des commentateurs tant de
passion dans leur voix c'est fou bref
regardons plus rien ça va
ça va être très dur parce que le produit
avait dessiné la ba ouai c'est les trois
favoris en devant way et y aura pas de
podium pour le 4.4 français parce que là
on vient pas les russes l'ukraine et la
grande bretagne
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu un problème dans
le trafic abba avec la grève ça regardez
comme elle est loin sa mère elle est
vraiment loin sa mère elle même et le
dis là elle est en train de créer faire
je suis loin sa mère le commentateur
écouter qui l'envoie de la force de la
lys qui dit avec toujours la possibilité
pour a dérouillé alors que floria à
donne tout ce qu'elle a mais
malheureusement ce sera ça sera pas
suffisant et wef l'oreillette a tout
donné mais la france ne sera pas sur le
podium mais c'est pas grave on kiffe
attendu et parlait pas vite ça revient
soirée revient fort well as pris ta vie
je pense à mettre juste paix depuis
donné
nathalie mineur britannique a temporisé
hu
j'ai jamais vu ça
patrick je n'ai jamais vu ça je n'ai
jamais vu ça elle et ça c'est un même sa
part sur twitter tous les tweets de
débiles profonds vous répondrai que ça
s'il vous plaît je trouve ça incroyable
cette remontée ce sont elles les a fumé
quoi croit la mecque et j'avoue le combo
des athlètes françaises qui sont des
petits canards et le commentateur qui
est ému aux larmes
non mais ça nous attend pas l on va la
salle un bon voilà oui c'est ce genre de
truc qui moi me rend très sensible aux
sports à très haut niveau je veux dire
et qui me donne envie de regarder quoi
je trouve ça beau tout ça dingue avait
il ya ce truc de on est tous des humains
on ait la même espèce ok mais y en a
parmi nous qui nous fûmes et c'est trop
impressionnant de les voir nous fûmes et
j'adore ok il ya un autre truc qui me
fait rire dans les compètes mais c'est
des trucs très rare qui arrivent et qui
sont liées au hasard pas méchant et
personne n'est blessé mais les petits
trucs à droite à gauche qui font qu'un
sportif et baisers et ça a été le cas du
coureur en bus mais ils donnent bon
petit compétition universitaire c'est
pas un truc on n'est pas obligé ou quoi
donc le mec fini sa course regarder ça
très vite ça me fût ce genre de faits
est qu il ya un [ __ ] de soi à la
perche à goûter et la corde du saut à la
perche ce bar va enrouler le mec était
premier de ce pack tuilerie
il est évident que cette corde en avait
après lui c'est sûr mec j'ai pas
peut-être le baron du courant ils
ligotent c'est gigot avec des cordes du
même genre chez pas c'est une vengeance
de corps mais il ya un truc d'air et ça
me fume parce qu'il finit 2e qu à cause
de ça pardon jusqu'aux doigts du malheur
des autres
vrbata mais c'est drôle bon du coup j'ai
regardé aussi des compiles de mouvement
sportif incroyable et ya le début de
celle-ci que je trouve souci du golfe
moi je connais très peu le golf je
connais le mini golf très bien mais le
vrai golf je connais que dalle et là il
ya un mec qui fait un tir je pensais
même pas ça peut aussi bloquer un trou
qui est très très loin il tire mec c'est
loin vous avez la balle c'est loin le
trou est vraiment long et là bas
oh
comment c'est possible ça m'énerve je
vais aller à la salle g ral et combattu
rope est calé bref volailles à ses
vidéos là dont je vais vous parler parce
qu'ils m'ont vraiment aidé mon attention
elles sont vraiment belles je trouve on
va continuer notre route sur le seul
sport et mec là il lie à de la pépite
lui il est dans un subside qu'on a flâné
un flash et puis c'est lequel
bref souvenez vous il ya un boxeur qui
soit une grosse droite et on voit la
belle réaction de l'arbitré avec ses
yeux qui sortent comme ça abbas et lui
en fait ce gars là je savais pas mais il
est connu aux us pour justement être un
arbitre hyper passionnés hyper investi
et en fait c'est très très fréquente de
vous de le voir faire des têtes pas
possible on est dans un état pas
possible pendant qu'il arbitres un match
regardez il est génial il y en a il est
tellement dans le match et calme md ou
en plein match il à fond dedans mais
qu'il est sur les nerfs et tous ces fous
mais gardé cette passion transpire la
passion avec il vit ces matches nous a
tellement mignon il ya vraiment un truc
mignon avec le sport
un athlète nord coréen essaient de
choper la jambe d'un opposant japonais
plantiers voix mais qu'il aurait pu se
faire couper la mala c'est pour ça que
j'ai à moi je fais pas terminé je me
chie dessus à cause de ça j'ai trop peur
de tout mais comme dans les dessins
animés là comme ça je vous fais la chute
est là le patac sur les doigts s'est
terminée cette fin de carrière au revoir
c'est relou obligé d'embaucher un mec
juste pour faire les clics à ma place et
tous ces rôles l'ayant qu'ils simulent
une conférence de presse
après un gros moral
[Musique]
les gamins rien ne change à partir du
collège tout le monde reste le même
assez génial c'est un gars qui regardent
le match de l'angleterre contre la
colombie de la coupe du monde et ça
s'est fini au penalty et du coup il est
dans les transports en commun dont kiel
ville truc à fou mais il veut pas faire
de bruit pour pas déranger les gens
autour c'est comme s'ils avaient regardé
la finale de la coupe du monde là dans
une bibliothèque mais au moment où on
gagne tu ne peux pas célébrer avec du
bruit s'ils écrivent ils pris carrément
[Musique]
aaa
c'est mignon mais que ces débats ce
geste le faisait devant les jeux vidéo
quand je joue en cachette georges boutet
un truc de ouf sur dofus où se trouve un
groupe pour un donjon en bout et je
faisais je vous jure je partage
totalement si leur train de vie c'est
génial le principal fait un choc à
traire tout le terrain sous le regard de
tous les élèves
non j'aime bien ça
[Musique]
omeyer ambiance trop bien c'est pourquoi
c'était pas comme ça mais j'ai
l'impression que peut-être des bêtises
mais j'ai l'impression dans les
universités américaines le sport c'est
vraiment un truc de ouf
il ya une équipe pour chaque université
les mecs sont dans l'équipe c'est le mec
les plus stylées du bahut fin et on ya
vraiment tout un truc autour du sport
que moi n'y avait pas dans mes
établissements en tout cas jamais de la
vie le principal il aurait tapé un
panier à travers un terrain de basket
toute façon il n'y avait pas du terrain
de basket alors c'est vide même les
joueurs de wimbledon se moque de neymar
à parce que neymar 6000 beaucoup ça
histoire quelques amalgames sûrement
complexé parce que le salaire des
footballeurs est bien dans la douleur
avec ses prix une bonne balle la balle
choix elle va plus de 110 km heure sur
le smash d'un joueur pro moi j'aurais
fait la réaction de ce gars mais pour de
vrai c'est sûr arden qui se tapent dans
la face qu'est ce que c'est que ça
[Applaudissements]
cette réaction
la réaction de ce gars croyable
tellement naturel les fans mexicains
sont venus à l'ambassade coréenne et ont
fait sortir l'ambassadeur pour lui faire
boire de la tequila est-ce qu'il ya
quelque chose de plus mexicain que ça
[Applaudissements]
à kédougou
je ne suis plus l'ambassadeur de corée
besoin de vous c'est adorable mais je il
a peut-être sauter dans la foulée le
gars c'est dommage lebron valide un
femme tout en haut du terrain faisant
les places dans les stades de basket
américain la place au premier rang pu
coûter des milliers de dollars et c'est
le tout dernier rang coûte 30 fois moins
par contre tu vois que dalle là les mecs
son tout dernier rang donc ils vont pas
grand chose mais tu pèses tellement dans
la vie quand tu fais ça et que les gens
ils s'excitent c'est fou envoyés sont
très contents parce qu'ils ont
probablement pas les moyens d'acheter
une place devant place à laquelle tu
vois très bien les joueurs je comprends
qu'ils aient été refaits que lebron
pense à eux qui sont vraiment loin c'est
mignon c'était un petit débrief la gamme
le plus mythique des allumages de flamme
olympique à barcelone en 92 à ces mecs à
la flèche où on l'a tous vu ça c'est
vrai que c'est incroyable le mec qui
tire méga loin allumez le assez
incroyable un mélange de game of thrones
seigneur des anneaux le riken morty de
jeudi rapporte quoi le meilleur moment
du tennis là ça va être mignon non c'est
du fan service je le sens ça me touche
moi ça ça me touche directe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est génial quand un sportif prend
10 secondes de son temps comme ça comme
ça en face le mec c'est le souvenir de
sa live ça va lui donner de la force
dans les moments douloureux de sa vie
quand il va se prendre son premier
râteau qu il va foirer son examen de fin
d'année quand son premier animal de
compagnie va mourir quand le pad et bien
écoutez voilà c'est la fin de cette
vidéo sur tous ces petits trucs de sport
voilà je suis dans ma phase 'pour la
première phase port de ma vie moi j'ai
commencé le sport phare la salle l'année
dernière et là ça fait six mois que j'ai
là j'ai repris en fait je trouve ça je
trouve ça vraiment cool vraiment
épanouissant surtout pour un mec comme
moi qui n'y connaît rien bref je parle
de trucs où la plupart d'entre vous
connaissent déjà très bien le sport je
suis vraiment on est vraiment une
minorité à connaître 0 comme moi en tout
cas voilà les gros sportif as qui égare
la vidéo ou qui sont fans de sport sans
même peut être de gros sportif 20syl et
je vous comprends enfin ça y est je vous
ai compris vie au mythe au vin alors
attention le but de cette vidéo n'est
pas de vous compliquer si vous faites
pas de sport il ya aucun problème et a
pas besoin d'avoir un abonnement une
salle de sport ça coûte cher vous pouvez
totalement faire des exo chez vous sans
rien et qui fait il n'ya pas besoin en
tout cas si cette vidéo a donné envie à
certains de se remettre au sport je suis
très content voilà allez je vais à la
salle je suis en retard et attends je
sais que la salsa se voit pas sur mon
corps dans la salle mais maintenant je
peux vous dire que ça fait du bien
[Musique]